Here some picture of what most people associate
when they think of chemistry.
They think of scientists
working on a bench
with the different vials
of different chemicals.
They might think of a mad scientist.
Some of them boiling and changing colors.
They might associate chemistry
with chemical equations.
Thinking about how different
things will react together
to form other things.
They might think about models
of the different molecules
that can be depicted different ways.
They might associate it with
the periodic table of elements.
And all of these things are
a big part of chemistry.
But I want you to do in this video
is appreciate what at its
essence chemistry is all about.
And chemistry is one of the sciences
that really just helps us understand
and make models and make
predictions about our reality.
And even something like the
periodic table of elements,
which you'll see at the front
of any chemistry classroom,
you take it for granted.
But this is the product of, frankly,
thousands of years of human beings
trying to get to an understanding
of all of the different
complexity in the world.
If you look at the world around us,
and it doesn't even have to be our planet,
it could be the universe around us,
you see all these different substances
that seem to be different in certain ways.
You see things like
fire and rock and water.
Even in the planets,
you see meteorological patterns.
In life, you see all of this complexity
and all of these different things
and it looks like there's
just like a infinite spectrum
of differentness out of there.
Of different substances.
Even in things like our human brain.
The complexity and the
electrochemical interactions.
And you could imagine as a species,
this is kind of overwhelming.
How do you make the sense of all of this?
And it was not an easy path,
but over thousands of years,
we did start to make sense of it.
And why it's very lucky for all of us
to be born when we are now
or to be around when we are now.
To be able to learn
chemistry where we are now
is that we get the answer.
And it's a partial answer,
which is also exciting,
cause we don't want the full answer.
But it's a partial answer
that takes us a long way.
We realize that the
periodic table of elements,
that all of this complexity
that we're seeing before,
that at the end of the day,
things are made of basic building blocks.
Kind of you could imagine the legos
that really make up everything.
And there aren't an
infinite number of legos.
There's actually a finite number of them.
We're discovering more all of the time,
well not all of the time,
now new elements are not
discovered that frequently,
but there's a few of these elements
that are disproportionately showing up
in a lot of what we see here.
These things that seem so different.
Well a lot of this is different
compositions of elements
like carbon and oxygen and hydrogen.
And even the elements
themselves are made of things
like protons and electrons and neutrons
that are just rearranged in different ways
to give us these elements
that have all of these
different properties.
So when you think about chemistry,
yes, it might visually
look something like this.
These are obviously much older pictures.
But at its essence, it's
how do we create models
and understand the models that describe
a lot of the complexity
in the universe around us?
And just to put chemistry in,
I guess you could say, in context
with some of the other sciences,
many people would say at the purest level,
you would have mathematics.
That math, you're studying ideas,
which could even be independent,
you're seeing logical ideas
that could be even independent
of anything that you've ever
observed or experienced.
And a lot of folks that
say if we ever communicate
with another intelligent species
that could be completely
different than us,
math might be that common language.
Because even if we perceive
the world differently
and think differently in certain ways,
math might be that common language.
But on top of math, we start to say,
well how is our reality
actually structured?
At the most basic level,
what are the constituents of matter
and what are the mathematical properties
that describe how they react together?
And then, or interact with each other?
Then you go one level above that,
you get to the topic of this
video, which is chemistry.
Which is very closely related to physics.
When we talk about
these chemical equations
and we create these molecular structures,
the interactions between these atoms,
these are quantum mechanical interactions
which we do not fully understand
at the deepest level yet.
But with chemistry, we
can start to make use
of the math and they physics
to start to think about
how all of these different building blocks
can interact to explain all
sorts of different phenomena.
This chemical equation you see right here,
this is combustion.
This is hydrogen combusting with oxygen
to produce a lot of energy.
To produce energy.
When we imagine combustion,
we think of fire.
But what even is fire at
its most fundamental level?
How do we get,
why do we perceive this thing here?
And chemistry is super important
because on top of that, we build biology.
We build biology.
And as you'll see as you
study all of these things,
there's points where these
things start to bleed together.
But the biology in, say, a human being,
or really in any species,
it's based on molecular interactions.
Interactions between
molecules, between atoms,
which, at the end of the
day, is all about chemistry.
As I speak, the only reason
why I'm able to speak
is because of really,
hard to imagine the number
of chemical interactions
happening in me right now
to create this soundness.
To create this thing that thinks it exists
that wants to make a
video about how awesome
and amazing chemistry is.
And then from biology,
you can build out on
all of everything else.
So sciences like psychology
and economics, which of course,
these things also leverage
math and other things.
But this gives you kind of a sense
of how we build up and how we
explain the reality around us.
And not one of these is more
important than the other.
These are all studying
incredibly fascinating things
that as humans beings
first became thoughtful
about their environment,
said, "Gee, why are we here?
"What is this place?
"Why do we exist?
"How do we exist?"
And chemistry builds models
for us to understand interactions
at a scale and a speed
that we can't directly observe,
but nonetheless, we can to
start to make predictions.
So that's what's really cool about this.
When you study chemistry,
you should not view this
as some type of a chore
that the school system
is forcing you through.
There are people who would've
done anything 100 years ago
to get the answers that are
in your chemistry book today
or that you can learn from
your chemistry teacher
or that you can learn
from a Khan Academy video.
There are people in the
world in the past and today
who'd do anything to be
able to understand deeply
what this is.
That they consider it a privilege
to be able to learn at this level.
And then to think about
where this could go
because none of these fields are complete.
We have very partial knowledge
of all of these fields.
Arguably, there's an infinite
more that we could learn
relative to what we know.
But what's exciting is that
we have such a strong start.
We're starting to make sense of it.
To really describe
everything in our reality.